Welcome back.
We'll now use a little bit of
what we've learned about work
and energy and the conservation
of energy and
apply it to simple machines.
And we'll learn a little bit
about mechanical advantage.
So I've drawn a simple
lever here.
And you've probably
been exposed to
simple levers before.
They're really just kind
of like a seesaw.
This place where the
lever pivots.
This is called a fulcrum.
Just really the pivot point.
And you can kind of view this
as either a seesaw or a big
plank of wood on top of a
triangle, which essentially is
what I've drawn.
So in this example, I have
the big plank of wood.
At one end I have this 10
newton weight, and I've
written 10 in there.
And what we're going to figure
out is one, how much force--
well, we could figure out
a couple of things.
How much force do I have
to apply here to
just keep this level?
Because this weight's going
to be pushing downwards.
So it would naturally
want this whole
lever to rotate clockwise.
So what I want to figure out is,
how much force do I have
to apply to either keep the
lever level or to actually
rotate this lever
counterclockwise?
And when I rotate the lever
counterclockwise, what's happening?
I'm pushing down on this
left-hand side, and I'm
lifting this 10 newton block.
So let's do a little thought
experiment and see what
happens after I rotate this
lever a little bit.
So let's say, what I've drawn
here in mauve, that's our
starting position.
And in yellow, I'm going to draw
the finishing position.
So the finishing position
is going to look
something like this.
I'll try my best to draw it.
The finishing position is
something like this.
And also, one thing I want to
figure out, that I wanted to
write, is let's say that the
distance, that this distance
right here, from where I'm
applying the force to the
fulcrum, let's say that
that distance is 2.
And from the fulcrum to the
weight that I'm lifting, that
distance is 1.
Let's just say that, just for
the sake of argument.
Let's say it's 2 meters and 1
meter, although it could be 2
kilometers and 1 kilometer,
we'll soon see.
And what I did is I pressed down
with some force, and I
rotated it through
an angle theta.
So that's theta and this
is also theta.
So my question to you, and
we'll have to take out a
little bit of our trigonometry
skills, is how much did this
object move up?
So essentially, what
was this distance?
What's its distance in the
vertical direction?
How much did it go up?
And also, for what distance did
I have to apply the force
downwards here-- so that's this
distance-- in order for
this weight to move up this
distance over here?
So let's figure out
either one.
So this distance is what?
Well, we have theta.
This is the opposite.
This is a 90 degree
angle, because we
started off at level.
So this is opposite.
And this is what?
This is the adjacent angle.
So what do we have there?
Opposite over adjacent.
Soh Cah Toa.
That's Toa, or tangent.
So in this situation, we know
that the tangent of theta is
equal to-- let's call
this the distance
that we move the weight.
soon.
So that equals opposite over
adjacent, the distance that we
moved the weight over 1.
And then if we go on
to this side, we
can do the same thing.
Tangent is opposite
over adjacent.
So let's call this the distance
of the force.
So here the opposite of the
distance of the force and the
adjacent is this 2 meters.
Because this is the hypotenuse
right here.
So we also have the tangent of
theta-- now you're using this
triangle-- is equal to
the opposite side.
The distance of the force
over 2 meters.
So this is interesting.
They're both equal to
tangent of theta.
We don't even have to
figure out what the
tangent of theta is.
We know that this quantity is
equal to this quantity.
And we can write it here.
We could write the distance of
the force, that's the distance
that we had to push down on
the side of the lever
downwards, over 2, is equal to
the distance of the weight.
The distance the weight traveled
upwards is equal to
the distance, the weight,
divided by 1.
Or we could say-- this
1 we can ignore.
Something divided
by 1 is just 1.
Or we could say that the
distance of the force is equal
to 2 times the distance
of the weight.
And this is interesting, because
now we can apply what
we just learned here to figure
out what the force was.
And how do I do that?
Well, when I'm applying a
force here, over some
distance, I'm putting energy
into the system.
I'm doing work.
Work is just a transfer of
energy into this machine.
And when I do that, that
machine is actually
transferring that energy
to this block.
It's actually doing work on the
block by lifting it up.
So we know the law of
conservation of energy, and
we're assuming that this is a
frictionless system, and that
nothing is being lost to
heat or whatever else.
So the work in has to be
equal to the work out.
And so what's the work in?
Well, it's the force that I'm
applying downward times the
distance of the force.
So this is the work in.
Force times the distance
of the force.
I'm going to switch colors
just to keep things
interesting.
And that has to be the same
thing as the work out.
Well, what's the work out?
It's the force of the weight
pulling downwards.
So we have to-- it's essentially
the lifting force
of the lever.
It has to counteract the force
of the weight pulling
downwards actually.
Sorry I mis-said it
a little bit.
But this lever is essentially
going to be
pushing up on this weight.
The weight ends up here.
So it pushes up with the
force equal to the
weight of the object.
So that's the weight of the
object, which is -- I said
it's a 10 newton object -- So
it's equal to 10 newtons.
That's the force.
The upward force here.
And it does that for
a distance of what?
We figured out this object, this
weight, moves up with a
distance d sub w.
And we know what the distance
of the force is in terms of
the distance of w.
So we could rewrite this as
force times, substitute here,
2 d w is equal to 10 d w.
Divide both sides by 2 you d w
and you get force is equal to
10 d w 2 two d w, which is
equaled to, d w's cancel out,
and you're just left with 5.
So this is interesting.
And I think you'll see where
this is going, and we did it
little complicated this time.
But hopefully you'll realize
a general theme.
This was a 10 newton weight.
And I only had to press down
with 5 newtons in order to
lift it up.
But at the same time, I pressed
down with 5 newtons,
but I had to push down
for twice as long.
So my force was half as much,
but my distance that I had to
push was twice as much.
And here the force is twice as
much but the distance it
traveled is half as much.
So what essentially just
happened here is, I
multiplied my force.
And because I multiplied
my force, I
essentially lost some distance.
But I multiplied my
force, because I
inputted a 5 newton force.
And I got a 10 newton force out,
although the 10 newton
force traveled for
less distance.
Because the work was constant.
And this is called mechanical
advantage.
If I have an input force of 5,
and I get an output force of
10, the mechanical
advantage is 2.
So mechanical advantage is equal
to output force over
input force, and that should
hopefully make a little
intuitive sense to you.
And another thing that maybe
you're starting to realize
now, is that proportion of the
mechanical advantage was
actually the ratio of this
length to this length.
And we figured that out by
taking the tangent and doing
these ratios.
But in general, it makes sense,
because this force
times this distance has
to be equal to this
force times this distance.
And we know that the distance
this goes up is proportional
to the length of from the
fulcrum to the weight.
And we know on this side the
distance that you're pushing
down, is proportional to the
length from where you're
applying the weight
to the fulcrum.
And now I'll introduce you
to a concept of moments.
In just a moment.
So in general, if I have, and
this is really all you have to
learn, that last thought
exercise was just
to show it to you.
If I have a fulcrum here, and
if we call this distance d 1
and we called this
distance d 2.
And if I want to apply
an upward force here,
let's call this f 1.
And I have a downward force,
f 2, in this machine.
f 2 times d 2 is equal
to d 1 times f 1.
And this is really all
you need to know.
And this just all falls
out of the work in is
equal to the work out.
Now, this quantity isn't
exactly the work in.
The work in was this force--
sorry, F2-- is this force
times this distance.
But this distance is
proportional to this distance,
and that's what you
need to realize.
And this quantity right here is
actually called the moment.
In the next video, which I'll
start very soon because this
video is about to end.
I'm running out of time.
I will use these quantities to
solve a bunch of mechanical
advantage problems. See